we are getting a first look tonight at
new documents Republicans say show
Justice Department and FBI bias against
the Trump presidential campaign chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge is here with the breaking
details
good evening Catherine well thank you
both Fox News has learned through an
investigative source new details about
the basis for the former FBI deputy
director Andrew McCabe's termination
McCabe was fired in March for three
violations of the FBI's ethics code
first uncovered by the Justice
Department's inspector general and then
affirmed by the FBI's Office of
Professional Responsibility they include
lack of candor under oath lack of candor
not under oath as was the improper
disclosure of nonpublic information to
the media about the existence of the FBI
Clinton Foundation investigation in
October 2016 after The Wall Street
Journal reported on a possible conflict
because McCabe's White took sizeable
campaign donations from Democrats for a
state Senate race McCain wanted to set
the record straight he instructed FBI
lawyer Lisa Paige an FBI public affairs
chief Michael Corden to work with the
reporter it was McCabe's a lack of
candor about the media contact that led
to his termination the investigative
source said the testimony of lawyer Lisa
Paige to internal investigators was
critical because it directly
contradicted her boss Andrew McCabe then
director James Comey said he never
authorized the leak in a separate
development text messages between FBI
agent Peter struck an FBI lawyer Lisa
page indicate that struck traveled to
London in early August 2016 to interview
a key witness just days after the FBI
opened an investigation into alleged
contact between Russian officials and
the Trump campaign the two FBI officials
appeared to debate amongst themselves
about what they will share with their
superiors at the Justice Department when
struck returns to DC struck rights I
think we need to consider the lines of
what we disclose to DOJ for example the
last stipulation notes we will not
disclose less than a week later the
texts are just a series of high profile
briefings begin on the hill and at the
White House there was no immediate
response tonight from a caves lawyer or
the bureau Brett Kevin thank you watch